carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
un placer que estén nuevamente en
nuestra compañía carrusel de las artes
los lleva hoy por el mundo de la alta
costura y daremos también un paseo por
lo más destacado del cine y de la
canción francesa
no lo sé
a
seis museos parisinos celebran al genial
gibson lo home con un diálogo entre sus
creaciones de alta costura y las obras y
artistas que lo inspiraron
en los estrenos del cine francés a
rihanna fútbol una comedia dramática
sobre la juventud de hoy y la muy
esperada en notre damme se quema una
impresionante reconstitución del
incendio que redujo a cenizas el techo
de la catedral parisina
y les contaremos los pormenores de las
victorias de la música las máximas
recompensas de la canción francesa donde
brillaron dos superestrellas el rapero
ahora el sant y la sublime clara lucían
y
[Música]
el gran modisto francés yves on love on
es el protagonista de una serie de
exposiciones simultáneas en seis grandes
museos parisinos estos museos ponen a
revelan al público las múltiples fuentes
de inspiración que el estilista
fallecido en 2008 encontró en el arte y
que le permitieron sublimar el cuerpo
femenino
y dos son los he visto bajo el prisma de
las obras y artistas que lo inspiraron
ese es el formato inédito de una serie
de exposiciones en seis prestigiosos
museos parisinos para celebrar los 60
años del primer desfile de ira son los
home así matisse picasso braque live y
van gogh o mondrian han entrado en un
colorido diálogo con el conocido
estilista francés
[Música]
este botón con esta serie de
exposiciones queríamos explorar hasta
qué punto son importantes las fuentes de
inspiración para un creador como surgen
las ideas cual es el detonador para
crear algo nuevo y sant logo tuvo una
multitud de fuentes de inspiración en la
pintura la escultura y también en la
literatura si lazio
los museos del louvre o bce de arte
moderno picasso y el centro pompidou
acogen en sus salas las creaciones de iu
son los ojos de su lado el museo para
ver a james and love on the país exhibe
las etapas de la confección de una pieza
desde el dibujo pasando por la
elaboración de los patrones hasta lograr
la forma perfecta
[Aplausos]
pero el problema chicos se relaja
bombillo la obra más emblemática es el
vestido monteón de 1965 que es quizás el
primer proyecto concreto de salomón
question inspirado en la pintura sand
logo un diseño más de 20 vestidos
llevando las líneas y colores de montaña
al cuerpo femenino es algo absolutamente
fascinante que ayudó además a la
difusión de la obra de montilla en
francia
en esta sala presentamos algunas
pinturas y sobre todo más de 40 bocetos
y versiones de una capa famosa inspirada
en la obra de obra que se puede apreciar
la obsesión de sant los únicas quien
trabajaba sin descanso hasta obtener la
combinación más apropiada era un creador
obsesivo que no descansaba hasta lograr
la perfección
te amo tanto el arte habría sido
seguramente un gran honor ver su obra
expuesta en un museo durante su vida
algunos museos abrieron sus puertas para
él como el museo de orsay en parís o el
metropolitan en nueva york'
pero fue en salas dedicadas a la moda
pero en esta serie de exposiciones en
parís sus obras se colocan al mismo
nivel que los artistas de los cuales se
inspiró y eso es inédito todos los
museos dijeron si para entablar ese
diálogo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos una mirada ahora a la cartelera
del cine donde encontramos una comedia
dramática y una cinta de acción que nos
proyecta al corazón de un devastador
incendio
[Música]
llega a las salas de cine rihanna food
cinta que describe el oficio de azafata
en una compañía aérea de bajo costo acá
son dos vive sin apegos ni
responsabilidades encadenando vuelos y
fiestas con amigos efímeros
[Música]
y eso
a través de este personaje interpretado
por la francesa del exacto plus
rihanna food desgrana las condiciones de
trabajo apremiantes y el estrés físico y
psicológico del personal de vuelo una
experiencia que empuja a la soledad y la
desilusión lejos del cliché de una vida
excitante por los cielos esta primera
película de manuel marí yuri lo justo se
presentó en la semana de la crítica del
último festival de cine de cannes
[Música]
participación bueno apoyamos
de los cielos pasamos al infierno en la
tierra con la cinta no está dando gol
una impresionante reconstitución del
incendio en la famosa catedral notre
dame de parís
[Música]
periodista no sé
esta cinta cuenta minuto a minuto los
acontecimientos de aquel triste 15 de
abril de 2019 cuando el techo de la
catedral se redujo a cenizas ante los
ojos atónitos del mundo
[Música]
acá no es una experiencia
cinematográfica única pero también un
homenaje al cuerpo de bomberos de parís
quienes enfrentaron las llamas en el
emblemático monumento de la capital
francesa
[Música]
llama educación cíclica
nuclear
[Música]
u
completamos este repaso del cine francés
con la cinta distinguida con el césar a
la mejor película francesa en 2021
ilusiones perdidas de experiencia no
link un largometraje de época impecable
basado en el libro del escritor honoré
de balzac
ilusiones perdidas narra la historia de
un joven poeta que trata de hacerse un
lugar en el implacable parís del siglo
19 donde reinan la hipocresía y el
engaño
[Música]
a
y llegó la hora de hablarles de los
premios de la canción francesa les
victoires de la musique una ceremonia
donde se entregaron los galardones a los
mejores artistas del último año y vamos
a ver eso ya mismo con nuestra
especialista musical natale olivares
hola natal ya fueron tres horas de show
a la francesa con dos cantantes que se
llevaron casi todo 3 horas de hecho y
ninguna sorpresa en esta edición 37 de
las víctimas de la music el rapero ahora
el sant se llevó tres premios y él ya
había se había destacado a lo largo de
todo el año con su nuevo álbum y un
documental sobre su vida ahora tres
premios lo convierten en el rey de la
industria musical
[Aplausos]
tres premios el del primer del mejor
artista masculino el de la mejor
creación audiovisual y de la mejor
canción
[Música]
el olor de la bencina una canción la
mejor del año según lo habitual de la
música y el premio que recibió por esa
canción una canción que es una fuerte
crítica al modelo socioeconómico basado
en violencia y que está en plena
decadencia
natalia y otra figura de la canción
francesa que se llevó dos premios fue
clara lucían y clara lúcida ni dos
premios como lo dice es el de la mejor
artista femenina y del mejor álbum
una clara alusión y hay que decirlo
lleva tres años arrasando premios en
francia recordemos que el habitual de la
music es un premio de la industria
musical pero sobre todo el
reconocimiento del público francés y
sobre eso hablamos con ella
dejamos con la familia de las víctimas
de la música pero también con la familia
de los amigos porque esta noche estuve
compartiendo el escenario con mis amigos
para el show de mi canción no es blanco
pero a mis amigos conmigo en el
escenario de las victorias y es absurdo
pero al mismo tiempo delicioso a mí me
gusta la colectividad y siempre me ha
gustado a lo mejor es por eso que estaba
tan triste durante los años de la comida
y que ahora tengo tanta emoción al
volver a encontrarme con el público y la
alegría también porque es importante y
lo merecemos
[Música]
sí
nos encanta
[Música]
de paso
clara lucían y le dedicó sus dos premios
a sus familiares y sus amigos más
cercanos que se convirtieron esa noche
en bailarinas en bailarines para
acompañarla en su show natalia y cuáles
fueron las novedades en estas victorias
de la música reciente de este año bueno
novedades y revelaciones más bien roland
fue a buscar
revelación masculina para el dúo que se
llama ternua y también revelación
femenina para bárbara para vi que se
destacó también este año
concursando en eurovisión ese concurso
europeo esa vez perdió pero ahora en la
victoria tuvo el reconocimiento del
público francés con ese premio destacado
que se llama premio a la revelación a la
revelación femenina y así reaccionó lo
escuchamos
[Aplausos]
y
me siento muy orgullosa y muchas gracias
a ustedes porque todo esto es gracias a
ustedes las victorias de la música es
algo que yo veo que yo sigo desde que
soy pequeña es parte de la cultura de
francia es el reconocimiento del medio
de la música de tus padres sobre todo el
premio de la revelación femenina es algo
concreto y es un premio que recibe todo
mi equipo toda la gente que trabajó
conmigo durante 7 años ganaron un premio
en las victorias de la música significa
a todos
y me dan es definida
y toda acción
vuela es la canción de baja sabía mejor
revelación femenina en esas victorias de
la música bueno terminó acá ua la que
soy muy francés y bueno para terminar
este carrusel vamos a escuchar un poco
de lo que fue clara luz ya niko en esa
canción los reyes tres victorias dos
victorias de la música para esta gran
cantante femenina muchísimas gracias por
su sintonía y hasta la próxima
[Música]
tu
perfil
[Música]
los
expertos al licor
[Aplausos]
quizá sí que sí
[Música]
con
el punto
[Música]
sí sí
soy
[Música]
yo te aseguro
que si no sube
el y del viento
[Música]
si
tú
tú que sí
[Música]
así es
pero las
no lo sé
e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sí
[Música]
estos requisitos y me tus amigos
el quieto un rondo
[Música]
[Aplausos]